sur ce plateau jean luc racine vient de
nous rejoindre directeur de recherche
émérite au cnrs et chercheur senior à
asia center bonjour merci d'être sur ce
château est ce qu'il faut parler de
volte-face de la part de washington
vis-à-vis des normes existantes du tout
du tout ça fait des années qu'un
rapprochement s'opère entre l'inde et
les états unis
ça a commencé sous bill clinton en 2000
après une période tendue qui avait suivi
les essais nucléaires indiens de 1998 et
ce qui a été signé
peu de temps avant la visite de donald
trump à new delhi est confirmée lors de
cette visite sa porte sur 30
hélicoptères 26 hélicoptères seahawk
pour la marine indienne
hélas ces hélicoptères pour l'essentiel
serviront à pister les sous marins
chinois qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux dans l'océan indien et les six
hélicoptères restant d'un autre type
hélicoptères d'attaqué certes
sophistiqué ça ce sera pour la dhr 1
pour le pan l'armée de terre indienne
donc je pense que la déclaration
pakistanaise rentrer dans la ligne
générale
tenue de longue date mais qui s'est
intensifié après le changement du statut
du cachemire décidé par new delhi en
août dernier est-ce que suite à la
déclaration du pakistan ce que le
pakistan
est abandonné par par washington en tous
les cas c'est ce qu'ont pakistan n'est
pas du tout abandonnée par washington
simplement washington joue sur les deux
tableaux d'ailleurs lors de son discours
ahmedabad dans cette espèce de grand
show que le premier ministre indien
narendra modi avait organisé en
l'honneur de trump tron a rappelé que
les états unis avaient je cite en
substance d'excellentes relations avec
le pakistan est l'invité ce qui va
complètement à l'encontre de la
politique traditionnelle indienne il
invitait une fois de plus les deux pays
à bénéficier éventuellement de sa
médiation
new delhi sous ce régime comme sous le
régime précédent n'entend pas passer par
une médiation pour régler la question du
cachemire le en octobre dernier à
vladimir poutine s'était rendu en inde
il avait rencontré le premier ministre
n'a rendra maudit lévis on avait évoqué
des contrats au niveau des déesses 400
russe on parle de plus de 5 milliards de
dollars de contrats
moscou est délirant 2018 c'est plus de
11 milliards d' échanges commerciaux est
ce qu'avec
ce contrat signé par washington ce qui a
une volonté de concurrencer la russie
via l'inde
non je crois pas la politique indienne
c'est d'avoir autant que possible ce que
les stratèges indiens appellent une
autonomie stratégique donc
historiquement l'urss puis la russie ont
été de loin les premiers fournisseurs
d'armement pour l'inde
aujourd'hui il reste encore un
fournisseur absolument décisif mais la
part des états unis augmentent le
problème pour new delhi vis-à-vis donc
de ces missiles russes sophistiqués les
s 400 c'est que ça fâche washington
ça rentre dans le cadre des sanctions en
quelque sorte que washington pourrait
imposer mais l'intérêt pour les états
unis d'avoir un partenariat
ce n'est pas une allée en simples les
indiens n'ont pas d'alliance militaire
sont des partenariats qui se renforce
la question a sûrement était débattu
entre donald trump et narendra modi lors
de la visite de trump il ya quelques
jours mais on n'a pas des qu'aux
particuliers
cela dit ça resterait un peu dans la
norme ci indépendamment de ce qu'est la
politique de sanctions américaines
ça resterait dans la norme de voir
l'inde acheter des armes à la fois aux
russes aux français puisqu'il ya
toujours la question des rafales qui est
posée et aux états unis avec la
déclaration de disques abad
comme quoi
ce contrat pourrait créer une
déstabilisation dans la région et après
les propos de narrer nhra maudit fin
janvier il avait dit que l'un peu je
suis peut vaincre le pakistan en dix
jours notamment au niveau du cachemire
s'il faut s'attendre à une escalade des
tensions entre l'inde et le pakistan
prochainement alors il peut y avoir une
escalade des tensions uniquement s'il ya
encore une fois un attentat terroriste
grave c'était le cas en février 2019 ou
là on a eu un changement de stratégie
indienne puisque à en croire new delhi
il ya eu un avion de chasse qui a
bombardé un camp jihadiste sur le
territoire pakistanais à proximité
immédiate du cachemire sous contrôle
pakistanais mais je pense qu'il faut
replacer les choses dans leur contexte
le pakistan depuis cette période et a
fortiori depuis le changement du statut
du cachemire qui est un territoire
contesté pour islamabad est engagé dans
une vive campagne internationale de
dénonciation de l'inde
il faut dire que les propos de certains
généraux indien sur d'éventuelles
opérations au cachemire en retard en cas
d'attaqué terroriste ne calme pas
vraiment le jeu mais je pense que
la déclaration de la porte-parole du
ministère des affaires étrangères que
vous citiez tout à l'heure entre dans la
normalité d'aujourd'hui la tension
diplomatique s'accroît mais ce pour une
part c rhétorique
merci beaucoup jean luc racine d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le directeur de recherche
émérite au cnrs et chercheur senior à
asia center